[Music]
Star Wars has been around for decades so
it's a sad but inevitable reality that
many of the actors who have appeared in
that galaxy far far away are no longer
with us here are a few faces from the
franchise you may not have realized
passed away
Admiral Akbar had a pretty small role in
the original Star Wars Trilogy in fact
he only appeared briefly in Return of
the Jedi even still the character's
appearance made him a firm fan favorite
as did the iconic line that is now
passed into pop culture Legend
[Music]
naturally then fans of Star Wars mourned
the unfortunate passing of akbar's voice
actor Eric bowersfeld who died in 2016
at the age of 93. interestingly
bowersfeld once argued that he thought
of his movie roles as a secondary career
that he had accidentally stumbled into
as opposed to his more solid work as a
radio producer he once wrote The Voice
work I did in movies was accidental I
was working with Randy Tom on radio
dramas at his technical Quarters at
lucasfilm one day Ben Burt sound
designer for Star Wars came by and asked
if I would audition for a voice in the
movie bowersfeld also voiced bib Fortuna
one of Jabba the Hutt's Associates and
he returned to the role of Admiral Akbar
in the force awakens which released just
months before he passed away
as he dies in the opening hour of the
film Uncle Owen can be considered a
pretty minor Star Wars character in the
grand scheme of things but his death is
the primary Call to Arms that sets Luke
Skywalker off in his hero's journey so
in a weird way Owen is actually one of
the movie's most important characters
making actor Phil brown one of the
story's pivotal players sadly Brown
passed away in 2006 at the age of 89.
even though he was well known when Star
Wars was made he'd face plenty of
hardships as an actor in the 1950s Brown
was caught up in Senator Joseph
McCarthy's communist trials and was
actually blacklisted because he refused
to comply with the house on American
activities committee's demand to name
Communists in Hollywood he denied being
a communist himself but was still forced
to move to London to continue acting as
it happened George Lucas was filming in
London at the same time and needed a
local actor with an American accent so
he brought Brown on board not long after
Brown was with Lucas and Tunisia filming
a new Hope's early scenes on Tatooine
a Powerhouse English actress Sheila
Frazier died in 2000 at the age of 79.
she had played a small but memorable
role in A New Hope as Luke's Aunt baru
the character dies early on in the story
so Frasier was unable to contribute a
lot to the film but just like Lars
Peru's death spars Luke into action
driving his character Arc through much
of the trilogy and even though her role
in Star Wars is small some would argue
that she's indirectly responsible for
Luke becoming the hero he is at a New
York Comic-Con panel author Meg Cabot
argued that Barry case suggesting that
Aunt beru's kindness and caring for Luke
helped him overcome the dark side and
defeat the Empire it also helped him
find The Compassion to look for the good
left in Darth Vader without whom he
never would have stopped Emperor
Palpatine so yeah nice work Aunt Peru
Drew Henley appeared in the Star Wars
franchise as red leader the pilot who
led Luke's Squadron in the strike
against the Death Star at the climax of
a New Hope sadly he was accidentally
credited as Drew Hemley at the end of
the film but hey he at least managed to
squeeze in a post-mortem appearance in
Rogue one thanks to the power of archive
footage in the first film red leader
actually nearly destroys the Death Star
he launches his Torpedoes at the exhaust
Port but his aim is slightly off not
long after his miss his ship is
destroyed and the poor guy is
subsequently killed Henley was a
well-respected actor when he was cast in
A New Hope but was forced to retire not
long after the film was released due to
his struggles with bipolar disorder
after working through his mental illness
he settled down to run a bed and
breakfast with his wife Henley died in
2016 at the age of 75.
Anakin Skywalker has been played by
multiple actors across the Star Wars
franchise but when his deformed weary
face is revealed in Star Wars Return of
the Jedi that's classically trained
actor Sebastian Shaw playing the role he
also portrayed Anakin's Force ghost at
the end of the original version of
Return of the Jedi before being replaced
by Hayden Christensen in subsequent
releases Shaw was mostly known as a
stage actor outside of Star Wars fandom
he was a member of the royal Shakespeare
company where he'd often play lead or
featured roles he was also a Broadway
veteran and was well known for taking on
Parts in daring and controversial plays
Luke is choosing to digitally replace
Shaw with Christensen in Return of the
Jedi sparked some controversy at the
time but Star Wars fans will still never
forget the reveal of Darth Vader's face
Shaw passed away in 1994 at the age of
89.
Jason Wing green didn't actually appear
in the Star Wars films in person but his
voice brought one of the saga's most
iconic villains to life win green was
the original voice of Boba Fett The
Intergalactic Bounty Hunter who tracks
down Han Solo during The Empire Strikes
Back when green was also a well-known
television actor when he auditioned for
Star Wars having appeared in a number of
different shows throughout the 60s 70s
and 80s he originally auditioned for the
role of Yoda but lost out on the role
and was cast as Boba Fett stead and only
recorded four lines for the final film
he's not even credited and it wasn't
until the year 2000 that the public
discovered who had voiced the villain
still it's a testament to win Green's
Talent That Boba Fett became such a
massively popular character nonetheless
when green passed away in 2016 at the
age of 95.
you may never have seen Kenny Baker's
face or heard his voice in a Star Wars
film but it's a fair bet you still know
who he is for most of the movies in the
franchise he portrayed one of sci-fi's
most iconic characters R2D2 R2D2 wasn't
a puppet or an animatronic like so many
other creatures in the Star Wars
Universe instead there was an actor
inside that Droid Baker was only three
foot eight inches so he could fit inside
the chassis used for filming and he's
the one responsible for crafting much of
R2D2's personality when Baker passed
away in 2016 at the age of 81
starwars.com wrote whether it was the
slow turn of r2's Dome to convey
suspicion or nervous wobbles signifying
fear Baker made a robotic being seem
very human while Baker played the Droid
in all three original films and two
prequels he also played an Ewok in
Return of the Jedi
Peter Cushing was a massive star when he
was cast as Grand Moff Tarkin in a new
hope he also brought an immediate
gravitas to the film oozing Menace and
calm and somehow coming off every bit as
intimidating as Darth Vader himself
Charming to the last
before appearing in A New Hope Cushing
was an icon in horror Cinema he appeared
in many of the Dracula and Frankenstein
films of the 50s and 60s and also
portrayed Sherlock Holmes in a few movie
adaptations after a long and illustrious
career Cushing passed away in 1994 at
the age of 81. despite this however he
technically reprized his role as Tarkin
and Rogue one a Star Wars story even
though the film came out over 20 years
after his death Cushing was recreated in
the film with state-of-the-art CGI
nearly climbing out of The Uncanny
Valley in the process nearly
even though Obi-Wan Kenobi died in A New
Hope Alec Guinness appeared in the other
films of the original trilogy thanks to
the power of the force his casting lend
some credibility to the original film
but he also infamously viewed the story
as in his words fairy tale rubbish
Guinness was a hugely famous actor when
he signed on for George Lucas's Space
Opera it won an Oscar for The Bridge on
the River Kwai and had starred in
Classics such as Lawrence of Arabia and
Dr Zhivago and while many of the leading
actors in Star Wars are big names now
they weren't at the time making Guinness
by far the biggest star in the movie in
1977. but why did he join the project if
he hated the material well there are a
couple of reasons first he thought the
moral of the story was admirable enough
second he wouldn't have to do any
publicity for the film and third the
studio offered him a massive salary of
course he ignored any fan mail he
received about Star Wars and hated
discussing his role as Obi-Wan sir Alec
Guinness passed away in the year 2000 at
the age of 86.
one of the most prolific actors in the
Star Wars franchise Christopher Lee's
career spans over 250 roles over the
length of his career Lee is absolutely
one of the Gods of geekdom and has
graced several of Hollywood's most
notable franchises here he portrayed
Count Dooku in two of the prequel films
attack of the Clones and Revenge of the
Sith Lee became a star due to his many
appearances in the hammer horror Dracula
franchise where funnily enough he
frequently collaborated with another
Star Wars Alum Peter Cushing Lee's
imposing figure and commanding voice
made him perfectly suited to play the
villain which helped him a great deal
and arguably his biggest ever film role
playing Saruman in The Lord of the Rings
a man of many talents Christopher Lee
also released a number of heavy metal
albums when he was in his 80s and 90s he
was also knighted served in the second
world war as a member of the RAF and was
attached to the British Army's
long-range desert group The precursor of
the modern day SAS he passed away in
2015 at the age of 93.
despite never having shown his face on
screen in Star Wars Peter Mayhew quickly
became one of the saga's most iconic
characters his performance as Chewbacca
helped bring a sense of real Humanity to
a character where many other actors
could have easily been lost beneath the
mask
laugh it up fuzzball Mayhew was a
hospital orderly when he auditioned for
Chewbacca and even kept that job until
after Return of the Jedi was released
the seven foot three inch actor then
essentially made his living off the roll
for the rest of his life attending
conventions as a fan favorite star for
decades he eventually reprized the role
in 2015's the force awakens nearly
everyone who worked with Mayhew on the
Star Wars franchise had nothing but kind
things to say about him after his death
in April 2019 Mark Hamill wrote on
Twitter he was the gentlest of giants a
big man with an even bigger heart who
never failed to make me smile and a
loyal friend who I loved dearly I'm
grateful for the Memories we shared and
I'm a better man for just having known
him
Peter Diamond was more of a stunt man
and coordinator than an actor with
almost 250 roles in the stunts category
on his IMDb page however he had a
variety of small roles in the original
Star Wars Trilogy and he had a large
impact on several memorable scenes some
of the Star Wars roles Diamond took on
include a Koba the Tuscan Raider who
attacks Luke Skywalker and garofalafoe
the guy who rats out Luke and Obi-Wan to
the Stormtroopers at the Mohs Eisley
Cantina he also appeared as various
helmeted or background characters in the
trilogy often when those roles called
for dangerous stunts his other
contributions to the original trilogy
came from his role as the stunt
coordinator he actually created two
different styles of lightsaber combat
used by the film Sith and Jedi Diamond
passed away in March 2004 at the age of
74.
according to the credits of The Empire
Strikes Back John Hollis played Lando's
Aid as he's not actually given a name in
the film however many Star Wars fans
know him as lobot the cyborg who helps
Lando calrizzi and fight back against
the Stormtrooper so the heroes can
escape Cloud City According to some
deeper Star Wars lore lobot originally
used his cybernetic enhancements to
augment his intelligence however during
a mission gone wrong with Lando lobot
was injured and lost the aspects of his
mind that made him human so now he's
essentially a computer operating the
human body his unique cybernetics allow
him to have a direct connection with
Cloud City's computer system Hollis
appeared in several other popular films
including most of the Christopher Reeve
Superman movies Flash Gordon and for
your eyes only after a 40-year acting
career Hollis passed away in 2005 at 77
years old
in A New Hope Jack Perkins was a part of
Luke's red Squadron during the assault
on the Death Star if Lu is read six and
unfortunately he couldn't contribute
much to the battle his ship
malfunctioned early in the fight and
unable to maneuver he was quickly shot
down by Imperial forces besides his role
as Porkins and A New Hope William
hoopkins also had roles in movies like
Flash Gordon Raiders of the Lost Ark and
Superman 4. outside of Star Wars his
most well-known role probably came in
1989's Batman where he played corrupt
Gotham police Lieutenant Max Eckhart he
was also a prolific voice actor as he
frequently lent his voice to radio plays
and audiobooks utkins died from
pancreatic cancer in 2005. he was 57
years old
Alex mccrindle played a very small role
in A New Hope but he was actually the
first actor to speak one of Star Wars
most famous quotes mccrindell played
General dodana who tells the rebels
their plan of attack when the Death Star
is approaching after explaining that the
death star's only weak point is a tiny
exhaust Port some of the Rebel Pilots
expressed concern Luke Skywalker speaks
up that the target isn't impossible
which prompts this line from dodana
then man your ships and May the force be
with you
the court is often mistakenly attributed
to Obi-Wan Kenobi who never actually
says that line in A New Hope Alex
mccrindle was known more for television
than film and A New Hope is one of the
only big name films to his credit he
died in 1990 at the age of 78. Jack
Purvis was one of Hollywood's most
well-known little person actors so it's
no surprise that George Lucas cast him
in more significant alien roles across
this original trilogy Purvis actually
played three different characters in the
three original Star Wars films he
appeared as the head Jawa in a new pope
the chief ugnot and The Empire Strikes
Back and Tebow the Ewok in Return of the
Jedi he was no stranger to the
entertainment scene as Purvis had been
in a touring musical group but fellow
Star Wars actor Kenny Baker the duo
traveled to many bars and clubs with
their musical comedy show Purvis also
appeared in several other memorable
films mostly in the 1980s such as Time
Bandits Willow Brazil and Labyrinth
Purvis died at the age of 60 in 1997.
Larry Ward might not be the most famous
Star Wars actor with only two movies to
his credit A New Hope and Return of the
Jedi but he loaned his voice to two of
Star Wars most memorable baddies in the
original film he played the voice of the
notorious Bounty Hunter Greedo
Japan
in Return of the Jedi he provided the
dialogue for everybody's favorite space
gangster Jabba the Hutt even more
important than giving the giant slug his
voice was hoping to develop the entire
language he spoke the foundation for
hutis was laid down by sound designer
Ben Burt he based a language on quechua
a language of a group of indigenous
peruvians Bert played quechua recordings
for Ward then told the actor to
improvise dialogue that sounded like it
Ward passed away in 2007 at the age of
63.
Andrew Jack contributed to the Star Wars
franchise in multiple ways fans might
recognize him as kaluan Emmett a major
in the resistance forces in the force
awakens and a general in the Last Jedi
he was also the voice of moloch and solo
a Star Wars story however Jack's real
contribution to Star Wars came as a
dialect coach Jack helped many of the
actors in the later Star Wars films
perfect their accents as TMZ noted it's
very likely that Jack taught John boyega
how to hide his British accent for the
part of Finn he also helped the actors
learn to speak fictional languages as
original solo director Christopher
Miller explained we asked him to teach
Alden ehrenreich to speak sriwuk I'll
always remember listening to them gargle
Roar at each other back and forth
yeah I speak a little now just listen
outside of the Star Wars franchise Jack
worked on accents and some of the
biggest films ever made including the
Avengers franchise and the Lord of the
Rings series in March 2020 Andrew Jack
passed away from complications due to
covet 19.
Richard La parmantier played Admiral
Modi the man who dared mock Vader's
Force practices during a meeting between
several Imperial officers and A New Hope
confident that the Death Star will wipe
the rebels from the history books Mighty
dismisses Vader when the Sith Lord
compares the death star's power
unfavorably to that of the force your
sad Devotion to that ancient religion
has not helped you conjure up the stolen
data tapes that's what causes Vader to
demonstrate the force choke technique
Marty later directs the Death Star
toward Alderaan and leads Imperial
operatives in blowing it up the
pomontier relished the role once proudly
describing mati as the only Imperial
officer who ever stood up to Darth Vader
the actor even started up an outefunct
Modi fan site and reprise a character in
a 2012 Xbox commercial that recreates
his most famous scene at the 66 year old
now passed away in 2013 he and other
Star Wars actors would have played their
roles once again in Mari now a fan
project by La promontier that went
through various permutations including a
comic book
things might have gone better for the
Empire if General tag had been involved
in overseeing the Death Star rather than
Darth Vader and Grandma Tarkin played by
Don Henderson tag is in the scene where
Vader chokes Marty cautioning his fellow
Imperial officers to take the rebels
theft of the Death Star schematic
seriously tag also expresses dismay when
Tarkin announces the Imperial Senate's
dissolution but neither Monty nor Tarkan
pay mucheed to the heaping helping of
Common Sense tag clings at them while
Star Wars gained Henderson recognition
outside of the UK Henderson himself
admitted to Star Wars the official
magazine that his involvement had
slipped his mind until he saw it with
his son in the movie theater it didn't
stop him from having a healthy acting
career that lasted nearly three decades
particularly gaining the claim and
attention in the UK for portraying
quirky law enforcement officer George
Bowman in the xyy man his career also
involved a notable role in Doctor Who
Henderson died on June 22 1997 just a
few months after his character returned
to theaters and the Special Edition
version of a new hope
though not a major character you'll
likely remember Eddie Byrne's Commander
Willard the first fellow member of the
Rebellion whom Leia interacts with on
Yavin 4 when she finally arrives though
a small part Willard actually does do
something fairly important in the film
namely having the Death Star plans
extracted from R2D2 so the rebels can
figure out how to attack the moon shape
Station Byrne was no stranger to two of
the higher profile actors in a new pope
in 1966's Island of Terror burn
portraying Dr Reginald Landers seeks out
help from pathologist Brian Stanley
played by Grandma turken actor Peter
Cushing and in the 1959 movie the
scapegoat burn plays a friendly
bartender who helps sir Alec Guinness's
character become better acquainted with
his physical double also played by
Guinness sadly the chances of the three
actors appearing in another film
together ended when Eddie burn passed
away on August 21 1981.
given how many characters in Star Wars
where armor or are aliens there are
plenty of actors from The Saga whose
faces you never see such as the case
with Des Webb who is the Wampa that Luke
and his Taunton run into while making
the rounds on Hoth while Webb himself
isn't visible to viewers as he's inside
a big hairy costume fans of the
unaltered original trilogy may recall
that the Wampa doesn't appear on screen
quite as much before 1997. lame Webb's
costume which was just too cumbersome
for the actor to pull off all the Wampus
Feats the Special Edition version of
Empire added more Wampa footage with
Howie weed stepping into a new costume
Webb's acting roles were few and low-key
interestingly however the final film
he's credited in morons from outer space
has an intro that emulates a scene in A
New Hope or Darth Vader's Star Destroyer
first appears Webb died on May 21 2002
five days after attack of the Clones
made its U.S debut
The Man In The Battered Mandalorian
armor in both Empire and Return of the
Jedi as Jeremy Bullock as Bullock
explained to sci-fi Central he was
actually juggling his days shooting his
Boba fetts with his evening job as a
theater actor the Pack's schedule didn't
affect his enthusiasm for the role
though he admitted to starwars.com that
the costume wasn't exactly the coziest
Bullock being the original Boba Fett is
well known to the Star Wars faithful but
perhaps not his common knowledge as the
fact that Bullock appears unmasked in
Revenge of the Sith as Captain Colton
who takes several of the heroes to
Coruscant to figure out why clone
troopers are killing Jedi he's also
Empire Lackey Lieutenant shekel who sees
his Leia when she warns Luke that Vader
has been expecting the young Jedi
Bullock appeared in several features and
in fan films afterward and roles that
paid homage to his iconic character he
passed away from Parkinson's
complications on December 17 2020.
Irish actor Ray Stevenson first ventured
into a galaxy far far away and Star Wars
Rebels as the voice of Mandalorian gar
Saxon leader of the Mandalorian super
Commandos he later reprized the role in
the Clone Wars animated series Marvel
fans might recognize him as Frank Castle
and Punisher Warzone or the mcu's
volstag his roles also extended into
other popular series on both the big and
small screens like Dexter the Divergent
series and Vikings Stevenson's
reinsertion into the Star Wars franchise
came posthumously he passed away on May
21 2023 only three months before the
debut of Ahsoka where he portrays the
mysterious balanced skull while
Stevenson is not alive to see fans
reaction to Ahsoka he's expressed great
joy in taking part telling Screen Rant
plus he considers the series sprinkled
with pixie dust
foreign